you
[Music]
when I was a child there was something
that happened that changed everything
changed my whole outlook on life when I
was about eight years old everyone was
talking about the fact that a great
scientist had just died
I still remember everyone was talking
about it made the front page of all the
newspapers and they put a picture of
Einstein's desk in the front page and
the caption said unfinished manuscript
of the greatest scientists of our era
and I said to myself what why couldn't
he finish it I mean it's a homework
problem right why couldn't he simply go
home and finish this project what could
be difficult that the greatest mind of
our era couldn't finish it well
to me this was greater than any
adventure story I had to know what was
in that book what was the problem that
the greatest mind of our era couldn't
finish well later I realized years later
I found out that it was the unified
field theory the theory to unite all
laws into an equation perhaps no long
than one inch an equation when it's
wrong that I will allow us to read the
mind of God that was the project that
Albert Einstein set forth but you know I
had a second role model how as a kid not
only did I idolize the work of Albert
Einstein and I had to know what was this
unified field theory I used to watch the
Sunday Saturday morning TV programs on
television and I was mesmerized by Flash
Gordon for the first time I saw this
whole new world open up a world of ray
guns and rocket ships and aliens and
beings from outer space and I said to
myself that's for me but you know after
a while I began to figure out something
first of all I didn't have big muscles I
didn't have blond hair I was not going
to be a Flash Gordon but I realized that
it was the scientist behind the scenes
that made everything work without
doctors archive there were no cities in
the sky without him there were no
starships he made the whole series work
and I began to realize something
and that is science is the engine of
prosperity everything we see around us
all the technological wonders that have
enriched our life and and created this
huge population on the planet Earth all
of that can be traced back to science
when I was a child there was another
event that helped the shape the person I
was my parents used to take me to San
Francisco to the Japanese tea garden and
I used to spend hours watching the carp
swimming just beneath the lily pads and
then I asked a question to myself that
only a child would ask and that is what
would it be like to be a fish what would
it be like to be a carp swimming in a
2-dimensional world a very shallow pond
where you can only go forward backwards
left and right and anyone who talked
about up the world of the third
dimension was considered a crackpot and
then I imagined a carp scientist there
and I said to myself what would this
scientist say he would say bah humbug
anyone who talks about the third
dimension the world beyond the lily pads
the world beyond the pond is an idiot
because you can only go inside the pond
that is the universe the universe is
only what you can see and touch and then
I imagine reaching down and grabbing the
scientists fish lifting him up into the
world of the third dimension what would
he see well he would see beings moving
without fins a whole new law of physics
beings breathing without water a whole
new law of biology and then I mentioned
putting the fish back into the pond what
would he tell his fellow fish well today
we physicists believe but we cannot yet
prove that we are the fish we spent all
our life in three dimensions going
forward backward left right up down but
anyone who talks about a higher
dimension the world of up hyperspace a
dimension beyond what you can see in
touch is considered a crackpot
until recently and now of course some of
the world's leading physicists now
believe that perhaps there are other
dimensions other universes other worlds
to explore and perhaps one day our
machines will give us definitive proof
of the existence of hyperspace
[Music]